so first and foremost there's guilty
tenants that have allowed me to be
pretty successful and they start a
couple really pure intentions it's funny
I think so he has so many cops moves on
it that you can rank it and I actually
think looking about right the most noble
way to roll what I mean by that is for
all of you no matter what you're
building
I recommend this is [ __ ] cool except
I can't talk about today it's something
I've seen pay out for the advice that
I'm giving that it's early anything to
help money and I love your building a
product that's due to material
entertainment whether you're doing I
would argue that everybody in this room
is a company or startup is a media
company first and then you're doing
whatever you're doing
literally I can you believe that wine
red wine business is now a media company
first and then we sell wine
so much so that in a week where we
watching our website and
that's how to exercise I think we do
that here's what happens even the
question I always ask is for all my
solution I think about it going
backwards which is how in the world can
I provide so much value that I basically
begin to fire myself and so I think we
can actually inject in your vehicle it
changes everything the woman playing at
our velocities in 67,000 Instagram
followers
so thinking about how do we provide
something to this audience that's gonna
make them reviewing it possibly share it
bring awareness so it starts with making
that religious decision if your your
concept that actually defines value and
so the basic thought for everybody it's
a massive ugly if you want everybody so
human if they see the female market
right no they kind of and none of us
want that none of us have it and so
that's number one never choose actually
stay with friends for example you don't
need abilities with their case of all is
the Facebook dark posts you reach every
single person on Facebook now Pascal
efficiently it costs me those knees
never so our own Facebook posts are you
google it and find out what it is
because it is probably as I thought the
word why on Google for five cents the
week Google adversity
don't
tactics that became a place for women
built to be as police state ahead it's
understanding that if you're marketing
to twenty five to four year olds they
should probably start early or snapchat
presents right now these are 24 months
without that title is gonna matter
because the way it's built actually one
thing people care about let me tell you
what you won't care about you care about
the app that the attention of ten
persons for a few seconds or a few
minutes to actually tell them why they
should like your find enjoy music being
able to is there's a supply and demand
issue on a lot of toughness that good
early Twitter days when I have a hundred
thousand followers on Twitter elected
something out because it wasn't as much
noise I get to insanity more engagement
and conversion that I do now with over a
million people are always to worry about
myth and everything when it comes to
selling business and snapchat
I made sure these actually have to hold
it it disappears the psychology usually
leads they're actually pay attention to
that piece of content is the tough part
is how it will give you in that
environment make something
do you take a picture yet become very
creative each one on top of it and it
becomes our skill set but that's why I
spent my time on provide value and throw
that out actually do it to understand
the current state of all the
opportunities like I can't believe not
obviously where company in the world
there's 24/7 365 University University
and we beat up on where and what the
markets moving to and start playing and
testing so that we need too much weight
it's that scale to matter for you you
already have the learnings of have in
creatives and have convert people to
you're ahead of the market on that
tipping point because there's always
this amazing one or two years of all
these platforms where if your life is
ahead of the market disproportional
return on that investment and you lose
everybody wait with that is well as that
skill and I wasting like I love snapchat
now because my customers not there and
that seems a lot to last mission
dispersed you don't have a good time or
a limited money to navigate these car
decisions today just comes out sleeping
this yeah you know how do you want no
ice I mean I've done a lot of testing
and several companies were not very
interesting tiny startup world where a
lot of people aren't willing to put into
the hustle is required to be successful
I I can't imagine anybody sitting here
and not they do you have one more
elevator to squeeze out and so he has a
differentiation between winning and
losing
then we are in a very respectful I don't
wanna disrespect when we are in a very
fun time about your land where there's
almost this audacity that there's a
belief that you should have a company
Midlands
you know and then it should work and
that's just not with the consumer base
and so something about